[Musique]
Véronique prince Michel David Christian
Dufour bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir Véronique
vous avez décrit avec beaucoup de
précisions la manœuvre
médiatique cette semaine employée par le
bureau du Premier ministre le groupe et
ma foi vous avez dit ça fonctionne bien
là ça fonctionne encore mieux parce que
ce matin il est dans le globalement
ce qui fait que le chef de l'opposition
officielle aujourd'hui
Ottawa sort et donne 30 jours à Monsieur
Trudeau pour fermer
mais juste un trou d'eau à indiquer aux
gens que c'est la meilleure façon de
venir ici au Canada comme réfugiés
et maintenant on voit le chaos
lorsqu'on ressources sont consommées et
utilisés pour payer le prix du chemin de
Roxane on n'a pas assez de ressources
pour aider des autres réfugiés et des
autres immigrants
je pense c'est important que tout le
monde comprenne que le problème du
Québec c'est aussi le problème du Canada
c'est qu'actuellement il est rentré tout
près de 40000 personnes au cours de la
dernière année il y a Roxane puis on a
dépassé nos capacités d'accueil donc je
pense le Québec le Canada
sont généreux mais en même temps il y a
une limite à ce que on est capable
humainement de faire puis il faut que
tout le monde soit conscient de ça nous
autres ça fait longtemps qu'on dit à
Justin Trudeau bon on sent pas là on a
depuis une semaine commençait à voir que
des transferts des autres provinces mais
il faut que tout le monde au Canada
deux autobus aujourd'hui
il faut continuer comme ça
alors Véronique oui parce que dans le
globe il a expliqué que là c'est zéro
qui doivent rester au Québec parce que
le Québec en a trop fait puis il faut
respirer
donc une nouveau sur le fond mais c'est
une opération qui fonctionne c'est une
opération de communication qui n'est pas
terminée Patrice dans les prochains
jours il va y avoir d'autres choses
parce que le cabinet de monsieur Legault
a l'impression d'avoir saisi le momentum
et à l'intention de maintenir cette
pression là en allant chercher le plus
d'alliés possible aujourd'hui on avait
des autobus qui se dirigeaient vers
Niagara Falls ils espèrent secrètement
qu'il y a des mères là-bas Ontario
Niagara Falls qu'on noie Windsor qui eux
aussi vont finir par sortir et dire mais
là parce que vous êtes en train de
transférer le problème chez nous on ne
le pas plus la capacité blend it au
Nouveau-Brunswick a dit nous on serait
prêt à en acquérir 150 c'est à peine une
journée de ce qu'on reçoit ici donc en
faisant en sorte comme ça que ailleurs
dans le Canada anglais une pression qui
soit mise sur Justin Trudeau et que
finalement ce soit lui qui soit obligé
d'agir parce que ce que le Québec crée
c'est que oui depuis une semaine on nous
dit que le fédéral a intensifié le
transfert vers les autres provinces
comme l'Ontario mais si c'était
temporaire si le fédéral fait ça en
attendant que les hôtels à Montréal se
vident pour recommencer à les remplir ça
fonctionne pas c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
l'intention de continuer d'aller la
pression Michel David va votre analyse
là-dessus depuis deux jours ce qui se
passe monsieur Legault a réussi à
transformer le problème du Québec en
problème canadien alors ça ça c'est déjà
énorme et on le voit ça fonctionne et
Monsieur comme vous dites monsieur
pollièvre a pris la balle au bon
maintenant le timing est excellent il y
a Monsieur Biden qui s'en vient Ottawa
dans les prochaines semaines on connaît
pas encore exactement la date et la
solution au problème passe
inévitablement par une renégociation ou
suspension de l'accord sur les tiers
pays sûr alors là Monsieur Trudeau sans
que parce que jusqu'à présent bon on
négocie avec les Américains mais il y
avait pas l'air de sentir tellement
urgence là il va y avoir une urgence
politique intérieure et il y avait
peut-être pas tellement le goût de trop
insister auprès de Monsieur Biden mais
là il va devoir le faire et on voit les
sondages là et au Québec en particulier
les libéraux reculent face au
conservateur alors je pense que Monsieur
Trudeau sans la pression monsieur LEGO a
bien compris ça et Monsieur palière
aussi ouais Christian
les deux derniers jours
la politique canadienne de façon
sérieuse c'est pas habitué à faire ça
puis là ça rapporte évidemment une
rondelle ne fait pas le printemps il
faut qu'il continue j'espère qu'il va
avoir un appui très fort de l'opinion
publique québécoise parce que depuis le
début de ce dossier là je trouve que
beaucoup beaucoup de faiseurs d'opinion
au Québec ont été très relation je
comprends complètement puis compréhensif
mais face à quelque chose qui était
totalement inacceptable pour ne pas
appuyer notre premier ministre là dedans
et ça rappelle aussi une chose c'est
qu'on lui dit toujours c'est compliqué
puis faudra négocier c'est un problème
essentiellement politique s'il y avait
la volonté politique de le régler ça se
réglera qu'un jour je suis content que
Monsieur pollièvre parle de moi on peut
le fermer demain le chemin Roxane
évidemment les gens vont dire c'est
compliqué puis ils vont passer par
ailleurs le problème si je me ressemble
il y a tout un système qui s'est
organisé autour de ce chemin-là donc il
faut de la pression politique c'est
totalement inacceptable c'est
irrespectueux pour les Québécois c'est
dangereux pour le français parce que des
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
sont pas qui sont pas
parce que vous avez dit ça quelques
jours aussi c'est très simple je vais
vous relancer si on ferme effectivement
puis là on verra ce qui va arriver le
chemin Roxane
ne croyez vous pas que cette pression
migratoire là va s'exercer ailleurs en
quelque part comme on le voit en Europe
comme on le voit partout
c'est sûr que ça réglera pas magiquement
le problème avant le 5 exercer ailleurs
mais ça va régler le méga problème
auquel on est confronté qui s'appelle le
chemin Roxane qui est connu qui est
organisé qui est financé donc on va être
confronté à autre chose qui vont être
moins graves aussi ça sera pas juste un
problème spécifiquement québécois donc
le problème c'est que je mets Roxane je
le rappelle c'est votre volonté
politique on peut le régler en 15 jours
mais Ottawa je suis à présent il y a pas
eu la volonté de politique et je
contacte monsieur polliath va parler du
moi en faisant il faut que ça soit fermé
d'ici un mois parce qu'il faut arrêter
de se dire c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué la moitié des
commentateurs au Québec dit c'est pas
terrible c'est bien compliqué
donc et vous vous en privez pas de dire
que c'est très simple mais Michel David
comme disait la pub si c'était si simple
on aurait réglé avant non bah oui ça me
semble évident et à terme le problème le
problème la volonté politique là elle se
manifeste quand on met suffisamment de
pression et actuellement Monsieur
Trudeau pour la première fois depuis
trois ans à ressentir une réelle
pression sur cette question là parce que
tant que c'est juste monsieur Legault
qui criait là ça le dérangeait pas
beaucoup Monsieur Trudeau là il y en a
d'autres et ça va ça va s'accélérer
l'Île du Prince Edward le
Nouveau-Brunswick sont bien ouvert là
mais la capacité d'accueil de ces
gens-là quand même limité et en Ontario
la capacité d'accueil est plus grande
mais je pense que la patience va être
plus courte alors d'une manière ou d'une
autre monsieur Trudeau va se sentir dans
l'obligation de régler le problème mais
pas simplement en fermant Roxane va se
fermer Roxane c'est c'est une solution
temporaire le problème il faut aller à
la source et le problème ça demande il
faut pouvoir aimer le mieux
et moi pourquoi je reviens toujours avec
ça c'est parce qu'on a toujours
l'impression qu'on peut pas le faire
parce que des obstacles Rigaux il y a
des obstacles techniques c'est pas vrai
on peut fermer le chemin Roxane la
semaine prochaine ouais mais même sans
le faire
qu'on peut la suspendre le Canada peut
unilatéralement c'est une dynamique
essentiellement politique et je trouve
que le Québec assez donné c'est très
malsain cette situation là et ils rend
ailleurs il y aura des pressions
ailleurs c'est assez longtemps que les
Québécoises subissent la pression quand
même que ils ont promis sont un peu de
pression pour le repas longtemps
Christian juste pour vous montrer là je
vais pas m'acharner sur vous vous savez
comment je vous apprécie mais juste pour
montrer un exemple comme quoi c'est
quand même assez complexe si on déchire
l'entente on a le droit vous avez raison
le Canada le droit de dire on la mette
côté là on envoie une lettre à
Washington c'est réglé si on la met de
côté l'entente il n'y a plus d'entendre
donc un demandeur d'asile peut arriver à
la colle puis rentrer au Canada dire je
demande de l'asile parce que plus d'un
temps de tiers pays sûr qui fait qu'on
leur repousse à Washington donc au
départ c'était une entente pour protéger
le Canada contre un afflux de réfugiés
qui venait ici comprenez que c'est c'est
une des petits éléments un des petits
éléments qui fait que c'est pas si
simple Véronique
non puis en fait deux points
mais non mais en fait l'argument de
Pierre poêlière justement va un peu dans
le même sens je pense que ce qui est
Christian dit c'est-à-dire que Pierre
poillière dit
ultimement on est un pays on est
responsable de nos frontières à partir
du moment où on décide comme pays qu'on
veut plus et qu'on les ferme on a tout à
fait droit de se retirer de cette
entente là donc c'est l'argument que la
même c'est pour ça qu'il dit ça peut se
faire en un mois c'est sûr que le
gouvernement le goût demain lorsqu'on va
lui demander est-ce que effectivement ça
veut faire moi va pas contredire ça
parce que je vais aller chercher le plus
d'allier possible mais encore une fois
juste pour le bénéfice de téléspectateur
là vous allez me permettre Michel
Christian Véronique si on l'a déchire
l'entente ça veut dire qu'à la colle un
demandeur d'asile peut arriver puis
demander l'asile au Canada c'est ça que
ça veut dire
pousser mais je comprends ce que vous
dites Christian c'est qu'on peut fermer
au moins ce qui est devenu une voix
Royal une voix pavée et organisée qui
est le chemin Roxane on peut au moins
fermer celui-là c'est ce que vous dites
c'est comme un abcès si on le fait on
n'a pas régler tout le problème je suis
pas naïf mais ce qu'on va voir à régler
après parce que chaque conclusion je
donne le mot de la fin Michel David bah
c'est exactement si on décide de
fonctionner de façon bilatérale les gens
vont rentrer dans l'ordre dans l'ordre
que là il rentre dans le désordre mais
ils vont rentrer pareil ok
un mot tour de table monsieur Legault
part on a vu la photo hier le groupe de
travail madame Brochu n'ira pas en
passant nous dit-on mais il part pour
aller négocier avec le Premier ministre
de Terre-Neuve labrador nouvelle entente
Michel David ça il y a des livres et des
livres qui peuvent s'écrire que ce sont
déjà écrit le Québec avait vraiment
gagné le gros lot avec cette entente là
à l'époque en 69 absolument et on fait
une fortune avec ça depuis au départ de
Terre-Neuve depuis ce temps-là vous avez
donné les chiffres précédemment là on
achète à 0,2 sous et on revend à 7 8
sous le kilowatt-heure alors on a fait
ça vous donne une idée alors il y a un
ressentiment énorme à Terre-Neuve qui
depuis des années ont essayé de faire
ouvrir le contrat ils sont adressés au
tribunaux je sais pas combien de fois
ils ont toujours été déboutés là il y a
une opportunité pour Terre-Neuve et pour
le Québec de voir s'il y a pas moyen
d'en arriver à une entente
c'est intéressant pour le Québec dans
les besoins énergétiques pour les années
prochaines vont être énormes et c'est ça
pourrait être intéressant pour
Terre-Neuve qui a de la difficulté à
trouver des débouchés alors
politiquement parce que c'est c'est là
que ça va se poser comme problème est-ce
que Monsieur furet est capable de
trouver une façon de de rendre ces
concitoyens plus ouverts à une entente
avec le Québec et est-ce que Monsieur
Trudeau monsieur Legault est prêt à
faire les sacrifices qu'il faut et
l'échec je crois comprendre que le
Québec serait prêt
à rouvrir le contrat c'est à dire que
d'ici l'échéance de 2041 on augmenterait
le prix que le Québec paie à Terre-Neuve
et un retour on se pourrait s'entendre
sur des développements futurs ça serait
déjà bien est-ce que les ternoviens vont
dire ouais mais en plus on veut une
compensation pour tout l'argent qu'on a
pas eu ça reste à voir et c'est oui
combien et pour compliquer la chose et
il y a toujours le problème des
négociations avec les Premières nations
souvenez-vous en 98 monsieur Bouchard du
tien Bouchard à l'époque où il était
premier ministre il s'est rendu au
Labrador pour rencontrer celui je pense
c'était auben qui était premier ministre
à l'époque précisément pour essayer
d'avoir comment on pourrait s'entendre
et ils ont même pas eu le temps de
discuter que les Inno ont dit non non on
vous bloque le chemin et il sort parti
chacun chez eux ça c'est pas réglé non
plus alors c'est vous dire l'ampleur de
la tâche Christian un petit mot
là-dessus
actuelle était très très abusive à
l'égard de terre-neuf le Québec
profitait de façon orientée mais ce qui
déculpabilise le Québec ça c'est une
chose dont on parle jamais mais sur le
pas historique c'est très important là
c'est qu'en 1927 il y a eu un jugement
du Conseil privé de Londres qui
délimitait la frontière du Labrador tout
le monde pensait que c'était juste
littoral le Québec constaté avec horreur
que la concert rentrait totalement à
l'intérieur de ce qu'on pensait que le
Québec oui Churchill fort donc c'était
comme une revanche sur le pain
historique du Québec faut rappeler cette
affaire là le samedi c'est bon non non
mais c'est vrai ça a été en hauteur
quand j'étais jeune on était choqué moi
je suis déjà négocié comme fonctionnaire
avec des gens Terre-Neuve vous savez des
troupeau de caribou là qui se
promenaient du Labrador au Québec on
négociait avec les autres puis ils
savaient qu'on pouvait pas reconnaître
encore aujourd'hui la frontière du
Labrador je pense avec les caribous à un
moment donné
quand est-ce qu'il passait la frontière
mais pour l'avenir c'est quand qu'on
puisse plus continuer comme ça on verra
pas sur le passé je pense deux parties
ont besoin l'une de l'autre là c'est le
temps d'arriver avec une entente qui est
fonctionnelle pour le Québec et aussi
pour le Québec un peu le gros bout du
bateau et moi je m'en excuserais pas je
te le dis là j'ai pas victime à ce
point-là mais on peut pas construire
comme avant c'est clair et Véronique ça
s'inscrit dans quelque chose de très
important pour Monsieur le groupe
l'avenir énergétique il veut construire
ça se sont testament pas son testament
mais son collègue son lait merci mon
Dieu tout le monde est gentil je vais
aller dans le même sens que Christian
dans le sens qu'effectivement il y a une
interdépendance chacun a besoin de
l'autre parce que même si Terre Neuve de
son côté dit on a d'autres options
François Lego de son côté dit on a 4 5
autres projets Hydro-Québec vers
lesquels on peut se tourner la réalité
c'est que pour chacun d'eux c'est
probablement le meilleur des excusez-moi
l'anglicisme mais maintenant faut
trouver une façon pour Monsieur fairy de
sortir de ça la tête haute en montrant
auprès de son électorat qui a réussi à
négocier quelque chose cette fois-ci qui
les avantages puis François Legault de
son côté doit également sortir la tête
haute parce que c'est un homme
d'affaires c'est quelqu'un qui est
habitué à négocier puis il doit sortir
de ça en montrant qui est allé chercher
le meilleur possible pour le Québec
finalement et je crois qu'il est lui et
Monsieur très enthousiasme face à cette
négociation il aime faire ça Michel ça
paraît il aime ces gens d'opération qui
aiment faire oui ben je vous dirais que
n'importe qui aimerait ça
mais Monsieur le goût vous avez raison
il va y avoir de l'argent à faire avec
ça pour le Québec c'est évident et la
grande transition énergétique ça passe
idéalement par ça plutôt que par des
nouveaux barrages au Québec
merci beaucoup à vous trois bonne soirée
bonne soirée pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI